in the 20s ion money more young adults
today live in their parents home than in
any other kind of household almost a
third of Millennials are under their
parents roof among those one in four is
not working or going to school and that
could affect their parents retirement
savings CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here Jill good morning
good morning so explain how this may be
a problem for the parents well you know
what we're really concerned about is
when your kids come home you want to
help them right you don't want to enable
them you want to help them get a start
but I start to hear these stories about
people who say oh you know I got a
second mortgage on my house because my
kid needs this or I'm not going to put
money in my own 401k because my kids
moving home and I need to have some
money or carpet help there where the car
payments keep them on all their
insurance whatever it is but we're
really worried because as you get so
close to retirement maybe your late 40s
and your 50s these are critical years
where we really want to see you continue
to contribute that's why I think it's
really important to have conversations
with your kids before they come home
yeah how long is this going to last what
the financial elite because I still have
a bedroom both for favorite daughter
favorite son and hope they never have to
use it on a regular basis but I want him
to I want them to know that they'll
always have a place but how do you
determine how much you're supposed to
contribute to helping them I said is
there no there's not a number and this
is what I think is critically important
it is something that actually keeps you
on track to hit your own retirement so
we want you to run numbers there are a
lot of free calculators that are online
there are also some paid versions of
calculators that can help you figure out
what you need to be doing but more
importantly how are we creating
financially independent kids if you are
enabling them again there's something
different between having a safety net
and actually doing a little bit too much
and again is that retirement is looming
you cannot make a mistake say that this
comes with a lesson in a little
Kourtney's Olivia or get ready when
you're planning your rewrite I think a
lot of people very much concentrate on
this old notion I must have no debt
coming into retirement first of all it's
nearly impossible for the vast majority
of Americans okay so don't put that on
yourself but more importantly think
about this when you are in your
retirement if you don't have a mortgage
that's one less payment but you don't
have access to the money that you would
have had in savings you need that money
to be growing you may need that money in
an emergency a health care issue so
having that what we call liquidity
access to money fast' may be much more
important than being mortgage free just
because it emotionally makes you feel
better it's my father used to like to
say you can't take the den to the
grocery store so be careful about that
all right help them but not at your own
expense thank you Joe thank you